[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages in the next half
hour then we'll see what's making the
headlines with the assistant comment
editor of the Daily Telegraph Madeline
Grant and the political editor of Hof
post UK Kevin Schofield and uh lovely to
see both of you so to the front pages
then let us start with the guardian
which leads with a photograph of 26 year
old Ellie Edwards who was killed in a
pub shooting on Christmas Eve on
merseyside it comes amid an announcement
from police this evening that a man and
a woman have been arrested in connection
with the murder
that is also on the front page of the
Daily Mirror where the headline reads
she was just so happy
the mail also leads with that story with
the headline the light of Our Lives
I mean while the eye discusses a survey
which says that two-thirds of Junior
doctors in England have actively
searched leaving their jobs and the
telegraph leads with energy companies
hoarding customers billions
well a reminder by scanning the queue on
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out those front
pages while you listen to our guests so
let's return to Madeleine and Kevin
welcome to both of you
um yes anyone hoping for infrastructure
and public sector cheer are not going to
get it Madeleine are they let's start
with rail shall we this is the guardian
which suggests that more than half of
all services from 15 of the busiest
stations have been delayed or discharged
as they say revealing the dire state of
our broken rail network
absolutely I mean it's just it's just
water wall chaos it's not the kind of
festive fair that you expect on a normal
boxing day
um but the guardian reports these
absolutely shocking statistics about the
levels of service at these busy stations
they also report that the Midlands and
the north have been especially badly hit
which I think anyone traveling regularly
in the Midlands or the North could have
told you
um I mean it really is just the most
appalling deal for rail passengers at
the moment I mean fairs continue to rise
albeit less than inflation something the
government is boasting of but it just
seems like that these appalling levels
of service that people receive has
absolutely no bearing on the sums that
they are forced to pay and to subsidize
the rail network whether or not it works
yes and um you know perish anybody who
has to use Manchester Oxford Road the
guardian analysis of rail delay and
cancellation data from the performance
tracking site on-time trains found that
Manchester Oxford Road was the worst
performing station in terms of the
severity of delays experienced by
passengers of trains departing from the
station 48 were delayed and more than
one in 10 were canceled in the year to
the 18th of December and that you know
doesn't really take into account Kevin
that the rail strikes of which we're
expecting more when people head back to
work next week
yeah you know it's almost as if people
can't really tell the difference of when
the the training workers are on strike
or not the service is bad regardless of
the industrial situation regarding
employers and the real workers so so
yeah um as Madeleine says you know as
perhaps you know quite noticeable I
think
um in terms of Midlands in the north
being worse than the South if you
remember the government wants to level
up the country now this is um an area in
terms of real infrastructure that people
really notice you know if you require
um the real Network to actually be
working properly to enable you to get
around to visit people to get to your
work on time and it's not working then
you're going to feel very annoyed to put
it mildly and you know what in these
figures I guess aren't that surprising
at the same time they are pretty
shocking and it's a pretty terrible
indictment of 20 plus years of real
privatization and it's no wonder that
people think you know let's just go back
to nationalization I'm not saying that
as the Panacea That's the Silver Bullet
but you can understand when people are
just sick to death of the current set up
and are willing to try something
radically different because clearly the
system right now simply isn't working
yeah and that's certainly the point made
by the guardian here uh two decades of
privatization has increased costs and
public subsidies they say pointing out
as you did about leveling up that it is
the North and the Midlands that are the
hardest hit but when we go to um the
Health Service uh here's the eye
two-thirds of Junior doctors are trying
to leave the NHS Madeleine
yeah that's right
um yet more bad news for the government
um the BMA the the doctors Trade union
have conducted a poll of their members
and found that 65 of them of the junior
doctors are actively considering leaving
the NHS
um and don't forget that the BMA is I
believe balloting Junior doctors in
January meaning that we could have
industrial action on our hands early
next year even after the various other
strikes that we've had in the NHS I mean
clearly I think what goes to the heart
of this problem is the the work
Workforce shortages that are bedeviling
the NHS and you know that there is
always this this fear that
um Medics will leave and move to
countries like New Zealand Canada
Australia which already recruit very
heavily amongst British doctors
um and you know alongside all of this I
just I find it extraordinary that
Britain has still maintained
um a cap on the number of Medics that we
can train you know we've been I think
doing things in a very short-termest way
for so long
um not training enough of our own Medics
and relying on overseas Recruitment and
um you know I think now a lot of the
short-termism of what successive
governments really is is coming to to
bite us yes I thought that changed
during covert because of a-level grades
but was reverting back again as you say
um yeah but we move on to the Daily Mail
which talks about the need for Locum
doctors
um they say this is an exclusive that
middle men as they put it are charging
the NHS half a billion pounds a year in
fees for agency staff Kevin and this
massive premium is on top of the wages
for Locum doctors and nurses so
effectively I presume it means the
agencies who are finding those staff and
applying them in positions where they're
needed and making a lot of money
oh yeah exactly I mean clearly you know
just following on from that last story
that there is an issue with Recruitment
and Retention in the NHS which requires
local um Health authorities to to go to
these agencies looking to recruit and
local uh doctors and yeah so these
agencies can clearly charge a premium
because the NHS is is frankly desperate
to get their hands on on people to to
fill their rotors and it looks like a
massive Payday for these agencies uh the
mail front page talks about one director
who who wrecked in half a million pounds
last year as a director of one of these
middlemen
um agencies which which as I say recruit
and the members of staff so uh so yeah
then this is money obviously which is
leaving the NHS it's not going to
Frontline care
um because as I said I haven't appears
premium and it just shows that you know
the answer to the nhs's problems isn't
simply giving it more money clearly a
radical reform as needed and I think
it's interesting to think that the
public now seem to be more
um receptive to this idea that the
current way of running the NHS simply
isn't working giving it more money isn't
working that the whole thing needs to be
reformed from from top to bottom and
it's maybe a time for more radical
political ideas and for a conversation a
grown-up conversation to be had in this
country as to what type of Health
Service we want and what we're willing
to pay for it and how we're willing to
to pay for it and these types of stories
I think will only add to that debate and
make people pretty concerned so that's
the real industry you want to change and
the health sector you want to change and
we move on to energy let's say if you
want to change that too and this is the
suggestion and it's a very strange
system this isn't it that you should
sort of be in credit now because you're
forward paying the rest of the winter
but any the point your paper is making
Madeleine is that effectively that means
energy companies are sitting on a lot of
customers money right now
yeah that's right because you know that
a lot of um the calculations seem to be
based on you know we're told when we get
our bill that it's often based on kind
of average meter readings for the area
that you're in
um regardless of you know your own
personal use
um I've had some extraordinary stories
from you know friends and relatives who
are amazed by the bills I mean even
though we've been told relentlessly that
the bills were going to rise I mean it
simply doesn't Accord with the way that
people have been incredibly careful and
the telegraph investigation has found
that some electricity and gas suppliers
are still hiking customers direct debit
payments even when in some cases these
customers are thousands of pounds in
credit and you know using much less
energy than usual so essentially what
sounds very much like a pretty dubious
method of calculating bills and you know
pocketing the difference
um the telegraph is where is aware of a
number of households whose energies
whose companies have put up their
monthly payments even though they're in
excess of a thousand pounds incred it
um and it's it's a tricky one because
you know I wonder if when companies do
behave in this way that seems to be well
extremely opportunistic that also
because for so long we've been hearing
that what we were told over the past
month that this is the cost of the war
with Putin that astronomical
astronomical hikes are to be expected
even if it Bears no relation to
customers
changing habits and so forth that we
just kind of accept our lot and forget
that as customers you know we do have
rights and in some cases we're being
charged way over the odds even in a very
difficult energy environment around
around Europe yes I mean I did speak to
somebody about this um in about
September and they said looking at your
bill you should really be you know in
credit now and it it pays through the
winter but as you're suggesting a lot of
people are not putting on their heating
so they're not actually using the
anticipated amount of energy and also
they need that money now so this
averaging out business doesn't
necessarily suit them but on the photos
Kevin of all the papers we see the face
of a young 26 year old woman who was
shot dead in wallacy village on
Christmas Eve
um named today as Ellie Edwards and uh
you know her family including her father
who lit tributes today absolutely
devastated yet another family on
merseyside who were devastated by what
seems like being in literally in the
wrong place at the wrong time
yes absolutely
um there's one friend as it's called
Who's saying that um Ellie had been
singing and dancing just before it
happened you're having a good time on
Christmas Eve as um millions of millions
were across it currently obviously the
first time since uh covert we've
actually been able to go out and enjoy
ourselves at Christmas time so for this
to happen especially this time of year
it's absolutely heartbreaking and you
know as I say your heart goes out to the
family
um just a terrible tragedy in the wrong
place at the wrong time and uh yeah it's
um yet another example as you see I've
I've gone crime on merseyside as well
which is extremely concerning but uh but
yet not surprising that that as a
picture which is on most of the front
pages tomorrow because it is I think
it's a story which is shocked the entire
country indeed so yeah lots more still
to come the next part of our program at
Michael Gove on the need to bring back
traditional architecture and uh this
story on the front of the Guardian two
which reads Studio homelessness soars in
a housing crisis back with that too in
just a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you are watching The
Press preview with me once again the
assistant comment editor of the Daily
Telegraph battling Grant and the
political editor of HuffPost UK Kevin
Schofield welcome back to both of you
um let us go to I'm going to move the
new papers out of the way sorry about
that Kevin
um the news of the Boxing Day sales
um you know you can picture your stats
on this can't you really but certainly
the way the telegraph is reporting it
tills are alive in high streets amid the
rail chaos um suggestion there that
expectations were low because of of
strike action but the bottom line is
that they're better than last year but
not as good as pre-pandemic levels
yeah exactly so I know where it's not
massively surprising but I think you're
right I think expectations have been so
low and that you know it's just uh
surrounded by Doom and Gloom on the
economic front for for so long that the
idea that no one's getting any money to
spend on on anything I've probably spent
what little we had on Christmas presents
so the idea that we've actually got some
money left over to spend on the sales
which is one which have once again been
brought forward to trying to entice
people into the local High Street is
obviously good news and ironically one
of the benefits of the the rail shakes
is that people have actually
um shot locally so local businesses are
actually having a better time of it
according to this story so yeah it's
obviously a time of year when
um even if the previous 11 months have
been pretty Grim this is the one thing
that people tend to cut loose a little
bit and um you know they might have got
a few a few quids in their uh Christmas
stocking from Santa so that will give
them a few extra supposed to go and
spend as well so any anything right now
which can give the economy at least a
little bit of a boost as we head into
2023 which by all expectations is going
to be fairly Grim economically I think
can only be a good thing yes we have to
remember that um a year ago we were
knee-deep in Omicron weren't we in the
uh you know had that wave hadn't peaked
yet
um to the guardian now Madeleine
um we know of many people who are
struggling to get accommodation uh the
rental sector is very tricky at the
moment but this is about student
homelessness that student housing is
reaching a crisis Point not seen since
the 1970s when students had to sleep in
sports halls or their cars so what's the
situation
but it's it just sounds appalling and I
mean I think we do often talk about the
housing crisis in terms of the the young
professionals and the young people who
are cut out from getting on the housing
market but I think you know this is an
underexplored aspect of it the way that
the housing crisis is pushing many
students into accepting incredibly poor
quality accommodation or even
um going into forms of what they call
um this is sorry this is the student
housing charity unipoll
um have said this what they call kind of
hidden homelessness uh which is things
like you know couch surfing and crashing
with friends and not having a secure uh
home of your own I mean they attribute
much of this to the fact that landlords
are increasingly either exiting the
housing market altogether or preferring
to stick to renting out homes to
professionals rather than students
um and they also say that it's now a
feature of cities and towns across the
UK I mean I remember when I was at
University about 10 years ago we you
know we paid through the nose for a very
small house that had damp and it had
mushrooms growing from the ceiling but
you know I went to University in a city
that was very well known for being
appalling and one of the epicenters of
the Nationwide housing crisis and it
really seems like this has ballooned
into being a completely
um Universal problem and and such a
nightmare for students many of whom
don't have
um
will find it difficult to supplement
their income in the same way that a
full-time worker would yes it sounds
like my housing experience as a
university student rather more than 10
years ago though I have to say anyway
moving on to the Daily Telegraph what to
do about the need for housing targets
and communities who feel like housing
projects are being foisted upon them
Kevin uh Michael Gove has has a solution
make the architecture more traditional
foreign
yeah I mean Michael Goff was a very
interesting cabinet minister he's
someone who you know takes the
opportunity with both hands and likes to
try and get things done and make his
mark
um now it's not always popular but he
doesn't he doesn't hang around
um and rest on his Laurels and this is
another example where he is uh looking
to use his job as level of secretary to
um to improve the architecture of the
nation I mean it's quite a huge ambition
but he's backing the establishment of a
of a national school for Urban Design
which basically is to try and improve
um the architecture a lot of the modern
design this report from um the policy
exchange which Michael gov supports says
that a lot of the current architecture
is very dull and boring and what they'd
like to see is as a greater emphasis on
um as it says in the headline
traditional architecture more
um aesthetically pleasing
um architecture which is I think a
pretty good thing Okay Kevin Madeleine
lovely to see you both thank you both
very much